you look fantastic you look like you
take very good care of yourself thank
you so much for noticing no I mean that
but you also look like I have people on
the show that look like and they tell me
oh I love working out they it's they
love doing and you strictly your
personality is you're not a person that
wants to work out thank you so much for
saying so thank you for noticing that my
physique is like a person who exercises
and my personality is not yes that is a
typology that I strive to really
transmit so much Kate Mulgrew who plays
red an orange she always says I don't
believe you work out in character she
says to me and I think that's because I
exercise exclusively in the dark I only
I try to not be found
exercising I'll walk into a gym class I
like gym classes that are very dark and
I put in earplugs I go to the back
corner I find the whole thing highly
humiliating the people modern people
what do they like they like putting on a
Katy Perry or something high fiving I
don't like that kind of a thing I find
that very minimizing as a human being I
don't want a high five you if let's say
you're the gym instructor I think of
then if you come up to me in the middle
of the class and you know like my eyes
are closed I'm trying to make it through
just survived by the skin of my teeth
and then you suddenly high-five me I'm
terrified and that terrible you talk
about a spin class is that what you're
talking about vaguely but I was trying
to be nonspecific on purpose okay you
know for shame okay because I went to a
spin class once and I loved to ride I
ride a bike like out in the world but I
went to a spin class with my wife loves
spin class and she said you got to try
it and I went there and there was too
much enthusiasm in the room yeah that's
what was getting and the woman up table
the front was growing that come on
everybody
it was
and wait come on everybody where do you
want me to go I'm on the bicycle yeah I
mean and and and why is it even
orchestrated this way incidentally I saw
a great video of you guys over the
weekend at a party involving wrestling
which I just want to let you know you
were dressed like a sort of a sort of a
turkey thing what are you from the
Mexico you had a stroke no we were we
were baby and you know when we did our
acts to coach show we did Mexican
wrestling and we arrested or we were
luchador yeah I do have another I just
think of it cuz they're exercising and
you guys were in leotards but I do have
a wonderful trainer Joe holder and but
he also trains like proper supermodels
like Naomi Campbell and so he's always
I'm always wondering like when is the
part where I get to be like Naomi
Campbell which is why I think the amount
of complaining has turned me into a sort
of Larry David of the gym that's why I
feel like I don't go I don't want to be
jumping I don't wanna work too hard I
feel like there's people there the
lights are on and Naomi is always on his
Instagram and I feel like I'm never
featured do you know what I mean I'm not
doing that's not it what are you wearing
when you work out you wear the cool
workout clothes I mean a whole like
plays there a t-shirt that says Gold's
Gym yeah you know bell-bottoms
yeah and Gucci love
and let me guess you're smoking at all
times yeah like you do the push-ups baby
[Applause]
you